yo no matter what Dawg don't snitch I
ain't saying nothing dude you know me I
die before turn snitch we tell them
nothing
they got nothing you think j-rock
talking hell no dawg
j-rock is my cousin that man would never
all right ha ha you demand a [ __ ] ass
ha
what up j-rock they hurt you up an ass
to me hurt you look I he just got back
from the [ __ ] snack shop what'd you
say to them man
[Music]
this is my man right here right my
brother
this man ain't never snitch on nobody
never whatever now look
we in this together where nobody say
nothing right right right yeah nobody
gonna say nothing about how big girls
shout out that a [ __ ] stop no no it
wasn't big girl what the hell are you
talking about the one hell no buckshots
the one that held up that liquor store
Pok jack
now where's he going
I don't know maybe he's going to the
bathroom some [ __ ] Eddie's going to dare
to snitch on us listen let me tell you
something that's my boy right there we
grew up together dad is a stand-up gene
that man would never snitch everybody
love Pizza time Pizza Pizza Pizza time
plan j-roc um where'd you get the pizza
back there I bought it can't you know
with muscle you made her to say no
[ __ ] game okay
if I find out you done snitched on us
I'm all busted camp and your tiny piece
of bread ass and then I'm gonna bury you
and my mother's basement was the rest of
the snitches what
we said listen where you gonna wiggle
we're going we go see see look look look
he's selling me out right now
no no he's saying that I would never
sell out that man I'm telling you let's
go let's go come on
you see what'd I tell you Rockwell huh
what'd I tell you your snitch ass
[Applause]
[Music]
you